cinq années se sont écoulées la grande
mosquée de québec a changé elle a été
rénovée la sécurité ya été renforcée
mohamed el habib sy aussi n'est plus le
même il était vice président de centre
culturel islamique lors du drame qui a
emporté six de ses frères musulmans le
29 janvier 2017 ne peut pas effacer un
tel drame
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on va porter
je pense à vie on essaie de tourner la
page
avec certaines difficultés
au lendemain du drame entouré de
dignitaires il s'adressait aux québécois
devant des dizaines de journalistes à
l'hôtel de ville de québec nous sommes
très touchés par cette solidarité et ça
fait chaud au coeur et ça diminue de
notre chagrin
vraiment
malgré le temps écoulé il se sera encore
soulevées par la vague de solidarité des
québécois beaucoup de mots qui nous ont
révisé leur position
on le voit facilement tout le monde dans
notre communauté le voir à commencer par
l'ancien maire de québec régis labeaume
qui est devenu l'un de leurs meilleurs
alliés c'est le changement d'humeur
après la tragédie mois pour moi j'ai
vécu caché comme
4h30 mohamed kabar qui tient un salon de
coiffure près de la mosquée est du même
avis
qui ont réveillé il sauve c'est quoi le
vrai problème le vrai problème ce n'est
pas les immigrants sup à l'immigration
vrai problème c'est le racisme le soir
fatidique une balle lui a traversé la
jambe une autre le gros orteil il fait
partie des cinq blessés de l'attentât
c'est pas fini
le on a du travail à faire en toc
société selon les deux hommes l'élan de
solidarité demeure fragile en raison de
politiques qui est juge polarisantes
le travail est ce que ça c'est pas un
modèle tu vois pour vivre ensemble c'est
pas ça le modèle mohamed el habib sy
déplore aussi que les gouvernements n'en
font pas assez pour protéger les
citoyens des propos haineux sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est cela qui cause les
projets de cette escale à sion de
nba n'ont pas besoin de cela il ne
comprend pas non plus pourquoi c'est
encore aussi facile de se procurer des
armes à feu au canada les deux mohamed
espère que les dissensions politiques
n'auront pas raison de ce qui a émergé
la tragédie qui ce changement il
continue à rouler va avoir une meilleure
vie meilleure ici mohamed kabar a bon
espoir que son fils âgé de 5 ans
trouvera ici une terre d'accueil où
s'épanouir ici marie pierre merci radio
canada québec